topics under discussion of course the
riots in the pacific northwest and
around the country foreign policy russia
china north korea pipelines all
compelling
all things that are covered widely in
the news but at the same time in this
country there are a lot of things that
don't get a lot of coverage
at this moment the most compelling voice
against abortion and planned parenthood
is not a republican
the most widely heard christian
evangelist in america is not ordained
instead he is a rapper married to a
kardashian who by the way everyone says
is crazy
kanye west is running for president but
that's not really the headline
the headline is that on core
conservative issues not political issues
like legislation before the congress
but on foundational questions about life
and
children and what happens when you die
no one with a national platform has been
more honest or sincere or effective than
kanye west has been maybe in generations
it's all pretty shocking really talk
about an unlikely messenger
but it's real check out west's twitter
feed if you haven't seen it
not everything he says is conservative
far from it not everything he says is
even
intelligible but when wes talks about
his faith and about the gift of human
life you start to ask yourself
why aren't there any elected republicans
who sound like that
they say they believe the same things
but if they actually do why don't they
talk like kanye west does
and the answer of course is because
they're afraid to but west
is not afraid he doesn't have to be he's
too famous he's made too much money
he sold something like 150 million
albums over the past 20 years
and really it's hard to cancel a guy
like that so what does the left do
in response to kanye west how do you
make kanye west shut up
the short answer is you can't so you
work to discredit him you go
ad hominem you ignore what he's saying
you attack him
as a person you don't engage with his
ideas you know you would lose if you
tried that
so instead you try to keep people from
listening to him
it's an easier job when you're dealing
with less famous people thanks to our
centrally controlled internet the left
can usually
silence dissent in an instant with the
press of a button
but with prominent wrong thinkers like
kanye west censorship requires a finer
touch
more artistic flair when the author jk
rowling had the gall to note that
biological sex is a
physical reality not just a state of
mind google couldn't simply
wipe her off the internet she's jk
rowling
she created harry potter so the left had
to destroy her
more methodically one british news site
compared rallying to the anti-semite
richard wagner and then dismissed her as
quote deeply unpleasant
so multiply that attack by hundreds of
stories and over time they are confident
and maybe they're right
that no one will ever listen to jk
rowling again
in kanye west's case they decided to
attack him as mentally ill you hear that
a lot now
but it's a relatively new tactic it was
just a little over four years ago that
cnn published a piece about kanye west
they highlighted his most famous moments
like the time he interrupted taylor
swift at the mtv video music awards
cnn described all these incidents as
quote controversial
but there was no mention of kanye west
being a danger to himself much less
mentally ill
no just controversial not a problem
and then west appeared to say something
positive about donald trump
and everything changed in an instant
kanye west became a
babbling lunatic the kind of guy who
pulls imaginary insects out of the air
and soils his own pants
a total nut case watch kanye west's
um event on sunday and you saw
right at least i saw a man clearly in
trouble
we met david bowen a democratic state
representative earlier this summer bowen
telling cnn
it's sad to see a popular music artist
like kanye be used as a pawn
to trick his own people and fans so new
questions this morning about kanye
west's
mental health after this tweet storm and
so-called campaign rally you see that
ignorance and aside
thought and behavior has been something
that's risen to the top
whether a clearly vulnerable mr west is
being used
to try to siphon votes away from joe
biden
they're sad they're concerned
he's in trouble oh it's all so fake
the feigned concern the oily fake
empathy kanye is vulnerable right
these people are actually worried but
they're not worried about kanye west or
his family they don't care about them
they're worried about the threat that
west poses to democratic party orthodoxy
and therefore to their power
they don't say that out loud they're
liars so instead they continue to play
the role of psychiatric nurse
here's the guy whose job it is to get
drunk on camera on new year's eve
letting kanye west know that he's
embarrassing himself and his dead mother
what i saw was a minstrel show today him
in front of all of these white people
mostly white people
embarrassing himself and embarrassing
americans but mostly african-americans
and now all of a sudden
he is the person who represents the
african-american community
he doesn't this was an embarrassment
kanye's mother is rolling over in her
grave
he's defiling the memory of his mother
sad
you'll notice that this group of cable
news mental health experts may be deeply
concerned about kanye west and yet for
all of their apparent medical training
somehow they don't appear to notice that
joe biden can no longer speak english
joe's fine he's not embarrassing anyone
kanye west by contrast
is deeply embarrassing to them mostly
because he's embarrassing to the
democratic party
here is someone who should be a democrat
calling out the most absurd lie that
party tells
we care about black lives that's why we
want more abortion clinics in black
neighborhoods
that's their position it is insultingly
stupid and
anyone who thinks about it knows that
when you love your kids you want them to
grow up and have children of their own
it's the main thing you want but if your
most consistent message to your children
was please end your pregnancy
they might start to wonder how you
really felt about them
and kanye west has start to wonder about
that
and things like that last month on
twitter
west wrote that he had quote cried at
the thought of aborting my firstborn
i'm concerned for the world that feels
you shouldn't cry
about this subject that's for sure
it's obvious but when kanye west says it
people might actually
listen to him and that's a massive
problem for the left
here he is last month my mom
saved my life my dad wanted to abort me
my mom saved my life there would have
been no kanye west
because my dad was too busy
[Music]
when was the last time you heard someone
famous say something like that
in public let's see never and then wes
went on to point out some of the more
inconvenient facts that the progressive
left wants you to forget
quote over 22 million 500 000 black
babies have been aborted
over the past 50 years west tweeted see
the media said
he's not well pray for him
of course what wes said was factually
true what's also true is that planned
parenthood was founded by someone who
wanted fewer black people
that's why she founded planned
parenthood her name was margaret
sanger and she once wondered aloud about
the appearances of quote exterminating
the negro population
end quote it's disgusting you can find
that on google
west has he knows it and learning it
clearly made him rethink his world
view here he is from a couple of years
ago one of the moves that i love that
liberals tried to do
the liberal would try to control a black
person through the concept of racism
because they know that we are very proud
emotional people
so when i said i like trump to like
someone that's liberal they'll say
oh but he's racist you think racism
could control me
oh that don't stop me that's an
invisible wall
no wonder they hate him now to be clear
kanye west is not a normal person and
we're not saying is he has said out loud
he sometimes suffers from something he
calls a sprained brain
we're not sure what that is we're not
pretending to be mental health experts
and maybe kanye west
is crazy we don't know but it's also
true
and wise people know this that at a time
like this a lunatic
time sometimes it is only the crazy
people who can see the world clearly